hello
how are you?
today
I
want to
speak Persian
usually
probably
this is the first time
that I have
made video
in the
Persian language
a few times
with
tutors
I spoke Persian
but
now
I'll
speak
in Persian
alone
for the first time
now
I am in
the middle of
a 90-day
challenge
this
video
is very
important
it can
be very
helpful
to me
so
I
can
watch
this video
later
all
my mistakes
I can show
for
learning
a language
it's very
beneficial
I want
to say
that
my tutor
in
Iran
Sahra
has been
very very
helpful
to me
many
things
about
Iran
history of
since
the time of
period of
Achaemenids
all
all Iranian dynasties
I
learned about them
a lot of things
in
other
words
only
not only
I learned
the language
but also
I learned alot
about
culture
of Iran
history
food of Iran
I learned
even
the political
situation
in Iran
economy
I
read about them
in Persian
I listen to them
always
sometimes
in
English
on the internet
I search
I follow
Iran country
Iran culture
to me
is very very
interesting
some of
the lessons
that Sahra
has
made for us
in
LingQ
like
mini-stories
history of Iran
like
many of them are there
so
for me
although
only
we
are
in
the
middle of
this
challenge
but
I hope
I
don't
speak well
yet
but it's
vary
important
to me
this practice
matters alot
to me
after
this
video
I
show
another
video
to see
my mistakes
i hope
next
next time
I will be
able to
speak Persian better
thank you very much
listeners
later
goodbye